et là j'ai la plus grande rigolade du
moment à on était sur cette appli cet
après midi au burin je vous le dis c'est
une appli qui vous met en femme mais en
enfant c'est à dire je vous le jure ne
manquait pas mal de thé vous devez faire
en direct ma tenue en enfants font frère
c'est un peu des pleurs on va démarrer
par benjamin castaldi va bien c'est pas
de gérer merci mon chéri merci alexandre
guerrier parvenait à oui j'adore mais
son père celui-là aller dépêche-toi
m'inquiète pas on va se voir un jour là
il m'a dit alors est venu met toi bien
regarder à la base il met toi a à dire
et la femme non mais c'était jure-t-il
il se sent bien là hyper belle alors
aller à l'école mais lui mais lui on
entend des racks a coûté valiha
attention regardez
vincent femmes tout le temps benjamin
castaldi en mars ont regardé benjamin
castaldi en enfants
[Applaudissements]
les minions celle où il est plongé au
fond là j'ai finalement femme savait
c'est soir de la moustache si l'eau
alors mais c'est qui ça ben je sais pas
c'est passé en france à se lancer
mais oui c'est l'enfant bah oui c'est
mais bon allez on dirait vraiment toi
mais genre à l'école explique côté
espiègle et en chine ont défilé durant
fille un jour oui ça va faire à moi cie
si ça marche c'est quand même moi j'ai
très envie de rester aussi sur igor et
grichka ça oui bah c'est vous merci
massez vous merci ben ouais
[Applaudissements]
non non mais juste derrière la marque
merci merci m'a dit ah ouais en me
faisant rigoler on dirait une meuf qui
va se présenter europe écologie ma merde
on dire franchement odile et dit oui je
t'ai vu marie bouchard d'europe écologie
merci d'être avec nous et attendons
alors en enfants gilles verdez ça j'ai
peur parfois rêveur et vous n'êtes pas
le seul à avoir peur ça me plaise à pour
ceux qui n'avaient prévu c'est la photo
qu'on avait du mal à faire même en fond
de vallée rioux me plaît
même en forte hausse des commandes en
douce on l'a jamais plus jeunes ouais
c'est vrai mais c'est très bizarre en
fait enfin avec les bogdanoff pour voir
si ça marche
j'aimerais vous devez voir le témoin sur
la vie retourne à l'idée folle ce matin
on en a pleuré de rire
il m'a dit tu vois qu'à des marques là
tu vois qu'il ya des marques ont été
d'abord la femme était d'abord le fameux
tamis la femme hélène michaud hélène je
m'appelle c'est vrai ouais c'est hélène
rollès le mensonge c'est quand même
hélène rollès qu'après un et tgv dans la
gueule on pas tous en même temps fait
voir en enfants aux années ça ne mange
pas surmonter mais là parce que tu étais
tu fais une offre quand même nom de
machine merci c'est juste un petit
lifting
gd convient dès qu'on me wade soit et
camoufler déjà donc bon elle valait bien
une est le chapeau tout va mais on est
inquiet de nature mais pas ton truc on
s'en fout merci récent rigoler la mine
deux millions cinq voire neuf et au laos
[Applaudissements]
cherchez bien
regarde toi des enfants malades xceed
deux camps se regardent enfin
[Rires]
les ministres et les minions histoire
mais vaut laisser gynéco en femme c'est
normal mais t es de christophe barbier
oui faut pas rester là monsieur
christophe alesi christophe barbier
barbie je vous dis en vérité on lui fait
confiance en sommes enfin non mais
jauzion christophe vous avez jamais
ouvert dans les chars question vous avez
pensé à vous présenter en politique
jamais je n'ai pas tiré sur toi faut
rester d'un côté du miroir ou blood on
vous a déjà approché
non jamais jamais répond évidence non
non pas du tout j'ai vraiment ils ont
beaucoup de mérite
moi je mettrais de chien je rêvais et
non s'opposent franchement est alors
attention aux enfants christophe barbier
regardez la tomate à côté d'une tétine
merci remarquer que toutes les femmes se
ressemblent
oui c'est vrai ça ouais
[Applaudissements]
enfin c'est tina turner ma mère adore et
on enfants n'ont pas été énorme
oui c'est à temps c'est pas vrai c'est
pas ces touareg famille d'accueil merci
merci
mais on veut voir la toxine
c'est vrai la tête et avec la banda
données sérieuses et m'ont dit réaliser
oui c'est la joconde c'est vrai que
c'est la joconde c'est est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à boire
là les gars là je vous mets bien d'en
face regardez regardez déjà bien vas te
tais cammas et attention à ce que vous
êtes prêts là je vous le dis c'est
cadart
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va alors les séries la chaîne
de bars à 8 ans elle n'est pas bonne à
toutes et à tous tes les folles sur
iphone la tdc on dirait un vrai gars
qu'on a eu dans son école